[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo le magazine des temps forts de
l'actualité de la semaine à l'assemblée
et au sénat avec à mes côtés en rien en
chine y bons joueurs et un gentil est
notre invité cette semaine et olivia
grégoire député de paris porte parole du
groupe la république en marche à
l'assemblée nationale joueur avoue et
avant les annonces des manuels macron
c'est au parlement qu avait lieu le
grand débat cette semaine le premier
ministre est venu s'exprimer à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
il a promis des réponses aux messages
assourdissant des français ce sont ses
mots elle les parlementaires
d'opposition se sont montrés sceptiques
sur la sortie de ce grand débat le
parlement a adopté la loi pacte voulu
pour relancer la croissance des
entreprises mais les oppositions se sont
unis pour combattre la mesure la plus
controversée la privatisation
d'aéroports de paris
pour la première fois un référendum
d'initiative partagée a été lancé par
les parlementaires
l'assemblée nationale a adopté mardi la
loi la taxe gars femmes
objectif faire payer les géants du
numérique comme google facebook ou apple
elle devrait rapporter 400 millions
d'euros cette année si le principe de la
taxe a fait consensus
une partie de l'opposition a mis des
bémols la jugeant surtout symbolique
[Musique]
et on commence par les conclusions du
grand débat présenté cette semaine au
parlement par le premier ministre
[Musique]
mardi à l'assemblée nationale puis
mercredi au sénat le chef du
gouvernement donc livré sa vision de ce
qu'il fallait retenir du grand débat pas
d'annoncer une série de leçons et des
chantiers baisse de la fiscalité nouveau
pacte démocratique lien social et
territorial à retisser le premier
ministre s qui sait des pistes mais ce
sera au président de la république de
trancher
le résumé du discours d'edouard philippe
à l'assemblée mardi et signé clément
méric un nouveau débat sur le grand
débat sans vote en lits décision
l'opposition s'en agace le premier
ministre lui tire déjà quelques leçons
reconnaissons le après bientôt deux ans
de gouvernement c'est une invitation
pour nous à corriger la méthode à
prendre en compte de nouvelles priorités
une nouvelle méthode de nouvelles
priorités mais pas de changement de
garde au contraire le gouvernement veut
poursuivre voire accélérer les réformes
c'est à ses yeux le seul moyen de
répondre aux attentes exprimées par les
français
c'est un puissant besoin de
transformation transformation de nos
outils transformation nos institutions
transformation de nos procédures
ce n'est pas le statu quo dont la france
a besoin mais c'est de transformation
pour ce qui est des annonces
il va encore falloir patienter sur les
sujets qui devront faire l'objet d'une
concertation
le président de la république fixera le
cap et annoncera l'ouverture de grands
chantiers
ces décisions seront puissantes et
concrète pourquoi est ce que c'est le
président de la république qui le fera
parce que c'est la logique des
institutions de la vème république
et ça ne me posera aucun problème au
contraire je suis plus surpris que
certains à droite fasse mine de s'en
étonner au sein de la majorité
l'hypothèse circule d'une intervention
présidentielle la semaine prochaine même
si aucune date n'est encore fixée
les jaguars ses discours des doors
philippe devant le parlement c'était
plus un passage obligé qu'un vrai
discours de sortie de crise c'était un
passage absolument obligatoire et et moi
j'aime bien regarder les choses en creux
souvent nous aurions évité nous
n'aurions pas entendu le pré ministre à
la fin du grand départ on aurait eu
alors toutes les oppositions qui aurait
estimé être lésés à juste titre puisque
l'ensemble des français dans les mairies
avec les les corps intermédiaires ont
enclenché le grand débat depuis des mois
je pense que ne pas prendre le temps
d'une discussion avec les parlementaires
auraient été mal pris mal vue mal venu
lui edouard philippe rémy nice se prête
à l'exercice il le fait avec
l'intégralité du gouvernement à ses
côtés il le fait à l'assemblée il le
fait au sénat et il le fait vraiment je
pense que c'était un temps nécessaire ça
aussi laisser la possibilité à
l'ensemble des porte-paroles chef de
groupe de s'exprimer
certains noms sans virulence comme
christian jacob mais ça a permis une
expression polyphonique des oppositions
sur ce grand débat je pense que c'est
globalement bon pour la démocratie je
pense que s'il ne l'avait pas fait ça
lui aurait été peut-être à juste titre
reprochés
on peut pas tout critiquer car l'entente
du premier ministre dit que la réponse
passe par la transformation du pays
s'ils le désirent cac a exprimé les
français finalement le message si on a
le bon cap
mais il faut aller plus vite et plus
fort je suis très vigilante sur ces
histoires de de cap parce que je pense
que l'une des choses qui seraient
dramatiques serait de faire croire que
l'atterrissage du grand débat confirme
intégralement l'intégralité la politique
économique et sociale du gouvernement et
des parlementaires depuis 18 mois
si ça avait été le cas car moi je suis
assez pragmatique je pense que nous
n'aurions pas eu la crise des gilet
jaune
il ya eu des erreurs de commises le
prémunit cela l'a reconnu le président
aussi au mois de décembre sur la taxe
carbone sur le rythme sur l'ambition ça
ne remet pas en cause typiquement le
fait que nous devons faire des choses en
matière d'écologie mais il faut
peut-être les faire mieux et en
accompagnant mieux les français
ce que je pense c'est que ce qui est
intéressant c'est que d'abord les
conclusions de ce grand débat
n'atterrissent pas exactement là où les
gilet jaune avait posé gérer leurs
jalons de combat que ce soit lié sef que
ce soit le rique ce type de thématique
extrêmement présent dans les
manifestations devraient gilet jaune je
ne parle pas des factieux violent je
parle des vrais gilet jaune légitime
dans leurs revendications
en réalité ça n'est pas exactement
l'atterrissage du grand débat donc je
trouve ça intéressant parce que ça veut
pas dire contrairement à ce qu'on entend
sur les ondes que personne ne s'est
déplacé que en réalité c'est un grand
blabla etc
ça veut pas du tout dire ça ça veut dire
que nous avons des français qui se sont
déplacés pour aller d'un grand débat qui
sont pour partie des actifs des seniors
on le sait est pour partie aussi des
jeunes le président l'a souhaité et ça a
plutôt été le cas nous avons des gilet
jaune qui n'était pas exactement les
mêmes
ce qu'on appelle csp catégories socio
professionnelles et donc on arrive à des
intérêts sage qui sont un peu différents
on arrive sur la baisse des impôts plus
de justice fiscale mais beaucoup moins
d'impôts on arrive sur une demande aussi
de plus de services publics qui
pouvaient être entendus pour le coup
celle-ci celle et gilet jaune
on n'est pas étouffé par les requêtes en
matière dies f
alors même que c'était numéro un chez
les gilets jaunes donc il ya tout un
travail si vous voulez qui consiste à
comprendre dans cette danse et
expression du grand débat en réalité les
français et ça fait partie de leur
charme sont très contradictoires et les
gilet jaune et les les français qui sont
déplacés sur les grands débats
on a aujourd'hui nous une sorte de
dialogue des problèmes qui s'est tenue
pendant des mois on doit les entendre et
on doit les réconcilier on doit
réconcilier ceux qui pensent qu'il ya
trop de service public et ceux qui
pensent qu'on paye trop d'impôts puisque
les impôts financent les services
publics c'est à nous de trouver
maintenant une conjonction de solutions
pour répondre à tous ces problèmes qui
sont très hétérogènes et ce que je
trouve intéressant c'est qu'on prenne le
temps de le faire
je fais souvent le parallèle avec la
médecine là on a ausculté le pays un
petit peu pendant trois quatre mois on a
écouté le pays
il faut le temps du diagnostic on est
dedans
toutes les données n'ont pas été
intégralement analysé il faut le
préciser il ya encore des données qui
sont en cours d'analysé
et ensuite on va avoir les ordonnances
l' ordonnance présidentielle
on va y revenir je voulais d'abord
peut-être vous faire entendre les
réactions puisque vous en parliez des
deux autres groupes parlementaires qui
se sont exprimés après le premier
ministre sur les bancs de la gauche
on a regretté notamment que la demande
un retour de li et c'est vous en parlez
réclamée par de nombreux gilet jaune
n'est pas été reprise par l'exécutif à
droite christian jacob a livré un
réquisitoire contre emmanuel macron
écouter 18 mois après son élection
monsieur macron a perdu la confiance est
plus grave il a perdu le respect des
français
en vérité le contrat qui le lie aux
français celui de son élection est un
contrat qui est totalement déchiré
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus réellement
d'un débat dans le pays aurait en
réalité besoin
mais ce serait d'une nouvelle élection
pourquoi une élection simplement parce
qu'en démocratie
l'élection est le seul juge de paix pour
s'assurer de la légitimité d'un
gouvernement
il va y avoir une réaction à ces propos
de christian jacob
je dirais un peu comme bruno le maire
qu'il a exprimé cette semaine en
hémicycle je crois que les républicains
savent plus trop où ils habitent
c'est originellement le mouvement
gaulliste ce sont les grands défenseurs
des institutions de la vème république
on entend l'a11 président du groupe
d'opposition par les délibérations comme
quelque chose de sinueux
est ce que le débat ait quelque chose de
signaux on entend la un président de
groupe de pétitions remettre en cause
l'élection d' emmanuel macron avec ce
terme des fractions que certes le
président avait employé mais qui est
quand même assez déplacés et je vais un
peu comme dominique schnapper l'a fait
cette semaine dans les colonnes d'un
magazine
je pense important aussi de rappeler que
les démocraties aussi peuvent mourir et
je pense que le jeu christian jacob est
extrêmement dangereux certes la
démocratie c'est le vote
mais la démocratie c'est aussi le débat
est donc je trouve que sont sa tendance
à aller vers une sorte de vote
révocatoire comme certains d'extrême
gauche est potentiellement dangereuse je
ne reconnais pas l'adn des républicains
je pense que c'est une manoeuvre
politicienne mais qui dans le contexte
actuel
est assez et je pèse mon mot à ces
irresponsables gelé beaucoup écouter et
vous savez la communication verbale
c'est important il était très agité
il était très énervé il éructe est et je
suis inquiète de voir que l'épopée les
oppositions après des mois de débats ne
savent nous dire qu'une seule chose soir
prenez les vieilles recettes avec les
vieux pots isf pour les socialistes
soient une nouvelle élection
autour d'un vote révocatoire pour les
républicains
elles sont où les idées qui ont
également fait des propositions alors
très bien
proposition à l'air sur le pouvoir
d'achat j'y étais j'ai siégé aucune
mesure nouvelle si ce n'est moins
d'impôt sur le revenu pour les tranches
basses
si ce n'est des mesures qui en fait
enclenchait 17 milliards de dépenses
publiques ensemble
ensuite est pas un gramme de gages c'est
à dire que nous avions là encore des
républicains est gelée dit à monsieur
abad ya quelques jours en plateau des
républicains qui sont ceux qui se
battent pour diminuer la dépense
publique qui nous propose un projet de
loi sur le pouvoir d'achat non financées
de 17 milliards d'euros
alors vous m'excuserez pour les leçons
ils repasseront aller après l'assemblée
nationale mardi 7 au sénat que le
gouvernement s'est rendu mercredi un
exercice légèrement différent puisque
après le discours des leurs philippe et
les traditionnels réponse des groupes
politiques
les sénateurs ont pu interpeller le
gouvernement avec une série de questions
trente au total et il a beaucoup été
question des territoires et de l'avenir
de la décentralisation quentin calmer
après la restitution du grand palais
après un discours à l'assemblée
nationale c'est donc face aux sénateurs
qui loire philippe a esquissé mercredi
les enseignements qu'il entend tirer du
grand débat national un discours proche
de celui prononcé la veille face aux
députés et où il n'est fait aucune
annonce à président de la république
présentera le moment venu ces
orientations
il l'a annoncé les décisions qu'il a
long qui rendra publics seront
puissantes et concrète
puis c'est au tour de chaque président
de groupe politique de prendre la parole
et l'exercice n'a pas fait l'économie de
quelques tirades il faut refermer très
vite ce grand débat le grand débat assez
duré et le temps des décisions mes chers
collègues est enfin arrivé mais il n'y
aura pas de sortie de crise sans un
langage de vérité
votre politique vaut 10 et vos noms dits
reste anxiogène anxiogène pour l'âge de
la retraite et sa fixation anxiogène
pour le statut des cinq millions et demi
de fonctionnaires anxiogène pour les
ressources des collectivités locales
anxiogène pour nos libertés publiques
anxiogène pour la préservation de la loi
de 1905
oxygène pour le financement des aides au
logement fiscalité santé logement
les sénateurs ont pu adresser 30
questions au gouvernement
poursuivez monsieur le ministre mais je
ne peux pas poursuivre ce président
bon les chutes hier le ministre un sujet
revient régulièrement la place des
collectivités locales faut-il un acte
iii de la décentralisation
comment renforcer les services publics
dans les territoires peut imaginer
effectivement des transferts nouveau
vers les collectivités territoriales
mais qu'on peut aussi conserver une
organisation territoriale de l'état qui
soit forte
après quatre heures d'une séance
extraordinaire pad annonce de la part du
gouvernement donc sur la sortie du grand
débat mais les sénateurs ont pu rappeler
leurs priorités politiques alors le
premier ministre a évoqué un mur de
défiance dressé entre les français et
leurs représentants est-ce que la
réponse à la crise démocratique devra
aller plus loin que la réforme des
institutions qui a déjà été présenté
l'an dernier mais qui n'a pas pu aller à
son terme
oui trois fois oui il y avait des bonnes
choses dans cette réforme que nous avons
porté essayé de porter mais que nous
avons été sur laquelle nous avons été
empêchés l'été dernier je pense
effectivement que ce soit la diminution
du nombre de parlementaires peut-être la
modernisation du rôle d'un certain
nombre de chambres la modernisation la
facilitation du rip référendum
initiative partagée
peut-être aussi d'autres types de
modèles et d'outils de délibération
permanente je les dis à quelques jours
je le maintiens je pense qu'il ya un
avant et un après gilet jaune et qu'il y
aura une nécessité absolue sur
différents types de procédures de
permettre une expression citoyenne
beaucoup plus forte sur les territoires
les sénateurs alertent depuis des
semaines sur le manque de confiance des
manuels macro envers les territoires sur
le manque d' écoute des élus locaux il
ya une mesure symbolique c'est celle des
80 km heure lundi lors de la restitution
du grand débat aimé edouard philippe a
semblé faire un mea culpa en tout cas
sur la forme
est ce que pour vous il faut assouplir
ces cas cette mesure des 80 km heure
d'abord manger bien aimé ce qu'il a dit
lundi il a dit non sans émotion le
premier ministre on l'a taxé de vouloir
remplir les caisses de l'état il
essayait juste de sauver des vies mon
père ayant été en accidentés de la route
je peux pas m'exclure de ce type
d'affirmation à laquelle j'adhère je ne
suis pas dans les petits papiers me
permettant de vous confirmer que vous
infirmez que ce type de mesure pourrait
passer à la trappe
ce que je peux vous dire en tant que
ressentie en donc parlementaires ont
vieux des annonces à venir du président
macron c'est que je pense comme je vous
l'aï dit au début qu'on ne peut pas
faire comme si tout était comme avant il
y a eu cette crise importante des gilet
jaune qui témoigne d'années et d'années
de cristallisation de mécontentement
aujourd'hui va falloir le président
pendant les gens qui viennent le
président va en sortir il faudra en
sortir avec des mesures fortes et
immédiates
il faudra aussi en sortir avec quelques
mesures qui exprime que on est capable
aussi de changer d'avis ou de faire
évoluer notre avis les 80 km heure
pourrait en faire partie
justement les yeux sont rivés vers le
président maintenant qu'attendez vous de
lui
j'attends ce que je viens de vous dire
j'attends trois choses j'attends un un
président et je ne suis pas très
inquiète le l'observant et le
connaissant un peu un président qui
reconnaissent qu effectivement cette
crise témoigne de problèmes qu'il nous
faut aujourd'hui mettre sur la table et
donc je pense que sur certaines mesures
il va falloir revenir ça peut être sur
les retraites la réindexation dont on
parle beaucoup
ça peut être aussi des mesures fortes
sur les 80 km heure ou sur d'autres
problématiques mais je pense qu'il faut
peut-être accepter de changer d'avis sur
un ou deux sujets point de il faut des
mesures immédiates pendant trois mois
pendant six mois pas dans un an
immédiates notamment pour le pouvoir
d'achat notamment pour le pouvoir
d'achat
on a fait énormément mois de décembre
avec les 10 milliards d'euros
il faut qu'on aille je pense un peu plus
loin et il faut qu'il y ait des mesures
immédiates exécutoire immédiatement
après je fais de la prévention je pense
qu'il ne faut pas être déçu que sur
certains chantiers majeurs je pense au
terme de la santé la santé vous voyez
n'était pas beaucoup dans les questions
qui étaient au sein du grand débat pour
autant c'est une des thématiques qui le
plus remonté et donc la santé on ne peut
pas être faire comme si ça n'était pas
un sujet majeur dans le quotidien de nos
compatriotes par conséquent on a le
sujet de la santé on a le sujet de la
dépendance je pense qu'il ya des des
sujets qui vont être l'objet de
chantiers à venir et de débats à venir
ne soyons pas déçu ce n'est pas une
façon de reporter à demain ce qu'on
pourrait faire aujourd'hui c'est une
façon peut-être de mettre la lumière sur
des sujets de société lourds qui nous
faut résoudre avec les français et non
pas contre les français
et je pense typiquement que sur le grand
âge il le débat pourrait se poursuivre
ça n'est pas une fausse ont encore une
fois de retarder l'échéance et les
solutions c'est une façon de prendre le
temps pour trouver les bonnes solutions
allez on en vient notre deuxième thème
la loi pacte et ce référendum
d'initiative partagée sur la
privatisation d'aéroports de paris
[Musique]
jeudi l'assemblée nationale a donc
définitivement adopté par un dernier
vote la loi pour la croissance et la
transformation des entreprises 147 voix
pour venues de la majorité 50 voix
contre venu de la gauche et d'une grande
partie du groupe l'est républicain le
texte à 6h thv un parcours législatif de
plus de huit mois
mardi il avait été rejetée une dernière
fois par le sénat qu'il avait déjà
repoussé deux mois plus tôt opposés aux
privatisations alors olivier grégoire
ces privatisations va évidemment revenir
elles ont concentré l'essentiel des
débats de la tension mais le texte aussi
ne se résume pas que retenez-vous
finalement de ces de cette loi qu'est ce
qui fait qu'elle va être utile à
l'économie française
merci déjà de rappeler qu'elle ne se
résume pas à huit articles qui concerne
la privatisation puisqu'elle en comporte
220 c 18 mois travaillent en réalité
depuis septembre 2017
c'est à peu près huit mille cinq cents
amendements les deux chambres confondues
c'est un texte qui a triplé de volume
entre le moment où on a démarré le
moment il a été voté non pas parce qu'il
y avait des manques mais parce que
l'ensemble des chambres ont voulu
apporter des éléments pour l'enrichir et
le préciser ça veut donc dire que c'est
un texte qui a intéressé les
parlementaires de tous bords et je m'en
satisfais plus tôt maintenant ce texte
il faut qu'il vive il faut qu' il soit
apx les entrepreneurs se l'approprient
et je dirais qu'il a un grand mérite
c'est qui vient du terrain et
aujourd'hui il retourne sur le terrain
de ce texte c'est un texte qui
contrairement à ce qu'on a pu nous dire
n'a rien d'un four tous un texte fournie
qui adressent toutes les étapes de la
vie de l'entreprise de sa création à sa
croissance à ces difficultés à l'export
et bien entendu au partage de la valeur
avec les salariés je vais je vais me
permettre de donner deux mesures qui
pour moi sont deux mesures phares de ce
texte de loi
premièrement la suppression d'un certain
nombre de seuils d'effectifs dont le
seuil de 20 salariés qui bloquaient la
croissance de nos petites entreprises et
qui me semble être très attendu
contrairement à ce qu'on entend sur les
privatisations géré c'est dommage de ne
pas parler de ce sujet de seuils
d'effectifs qui bloquent depuis des
années nos pme et aussi sur le seuil de
50 où on allège un certain nombre de
choses
deuxièmement la suppression du forfait
social qui doit permettre aux
entrepreneurs de faire des primes
d'intéressement et de participation de
façon moins chers pour eux et donc plus
intéressante pour les salariés une
mesure économique pour les entrepreneurs
typiquement une mesure sociale pour les
salariés
c'est un texte qui est équilibré qui est
très opérationnels et c'est un texte qui
est pas dans le dans le bavardage
contrairement à ce qu'on a pu parfois
lui opposer c'est un texte du concret à
nous maintenant de l'expliquer aux
entrepreneurs alors l'adoption de cette
loi pâques devaient normalement marquer
le point final de longs mois de débats
sur le texte mais c'était sans compter
sur les oppositions qui se sont
exceptionnellement unis pour sortir une
dernière carte de leur chapeau un
référendum d'initiative partagée pour
remettre en cause la privatisation
d'aéroports de paris
plus de 240 parlementaires ont signé le
texte ouvrant la voie à une possible
consultation des français
résumé signée alice rougerie avec samira
soit vous un petit mot ils veulent tous
prendre la parole à l'assemblée au sénat
en tout onze groupes parlementaires ont
lancé le référendum
du jamais vu nous avons converger dans
l'hémicycle de la france un soumises
jusqu'au aux républicains pour dire au
gouvernement que cette privatisation des
aéroports de paris d'abord n'avait rien
à faire dans la loi pâques
c'est une initiative totalement inédite
je ne sais pas sur quoi y ait plusieurs
fois s'est-il de photos profitez-en
crois que ça montre la volonté et la
démarche qui est la nôtre
comme l'a très bien dit gilles que les
intérêts fondamentaux notre pays au
travers d'alépé sont naturellement
menacée ça n'a pourtant pas été si
simple
dans un premier temps selon nos
informations les républicains étaient
réticents à l'idée de signer un test
avec la france en souffre
simple malentendu à cause d'un problème
administratif assure gilles carez la
proposer aux collègues de signer et tous
ceux qui sont d'accord singh parce que
je vous rappelle qu'il faut quand même
20% de signataires sais pas si évident
c'est la première fois vous l'avez
observé qu' on va des républicains
jusqu'à nous donc c'est normal que
appartement aussi inédit ça se passe pas
sans péripéties mais c'est des
péripéties faut évidemment si nous tous
ensemble le texte avec les signatures
des insoumis et déposé sur le bureau du
président de l'assemblée nationale qui
le transmet au conseil constitutionnel
il va y avoir les parlementaires de
droite comme de gauche ont exprimé leur
opposition à cette mesure durant tout le
parcours parlementaire du texte est ce
que finalement ce référendum
d'initiative partagée ce n'est pas la
suite logique de leur opposition
c'est peut-être la suite logique de
plutôt de une relative volonté
d'obstruction
je rappelle qu'en première lecture les
républicains se sont abstenus en
hémicycle ils n'ont pas voté contre
je rappelle qu'au sénat bruno retailleau
par exemple n'a pas signé ce rythme je
rappelle que laurent wauquiez la droite
et la gauche se sont animées fait que
veut dire le président du groupe
d'opposition des républicains ne
soutient pas cette initiative laurent
wauquiez sont tient assez éloigné aussi
je pense que je vais être très clair le
rip je suis pour je voulais dit tout à
l'heure je suis même pour un rythme
moderniser plus faciles plus simples
mais je pense que déclencher un rip à 48
heures du vote définitif de la loi est
une manoeuvre de communication politique
je suis par ailleurs un peu étonné de
l'attelage qu'on a qualifié de baroque
et soyons précis qui va de l'extrême
gauche
je sais que ça dérange je me suis
coquerel mais à l'extrême droite
monsieur bardella il ya quelques jours a
affirmé soutenir ce rythme la dp donc en
fait ça va de l'extrême gauche à
l'extrême droite on a là des gens qui
n'ont rien en commun si ce n'est la
volonté de bloquer le gouvernement alors
est ce qu'il ya un risque pour le
processus de privatisation quand
est-elle prévue quel était le calendrier
est ce qu'il va devoir être remis en
cause le calendrier est encore
souple dans les mois qui viennent ya un
cahier des charges qui a été élaboré
encore une fois moi je pense que c'est
une procédure louable mais je pense que
l'acte iv sur adp
en réalité à défaut d'avoir pu l'activer
sur l' isf parce que ce n'est pas faute
d'avoir essayé pendant des mois
notamment les socialistes ont essayé
d'activer ces horribles sur l' isf
n'ayant pas réussi sont rabattus sur adp
je pense que c'est de la tactique
politique je pense que en réalité ça ne
remet pas en question le texte mais vous
savez il ya j'écoutais la familia jeudi
en l'occurrence j'écoutais alexis
corbière qui disait mais vous êtes
contre serait parce que vous avez peur
du peuple
moi j'ai pas peur du peuple je voulais
dit j'ai peur de la mise à mal du modèle
démocratique
on n'a pas voté ce texte de loi ça veut
dire quoi et marc fesneau l'a dit très
bien ça veut dire que à ce moment là les
parlementaires sont capables de se
saisir pour contrer un texte qui n'a pas
été voté et donc de délégitimer un
travail parlementaire sur lequel ils ont
travaillé depuis dix mois et je pense
que il faut pas il faut être vigilant
dans les semaines qui viennent notamment
à la chute du grand débat et avec les
propositions du président la démocratie
participative ne doit pas rentrer en
opposition avec la démocratie
représentative et en ça je pense que
c'est un tour de passe passe qui est
potentiellement dangereux après encore
une fois on n'a pas peur du peuple et
c'est très bien que ce rip se dévouent
des poids nous verrons où il arrivera
allez on va terminer très rapidement
avec l'assemblée nationale qui a adopté
mardi la taxe sur les géants du
numérique taxe gars femmes pour google
apple facebook amazon et microsoft il
échappé jusqu'ici largement à l'impôt
désormais devront prendre leur part
puisque les députés l'ont très largement
voté 80 une voix contre 7 le ministre de
l economie bruno le maire s'est félicité
que la france soit pioneer en la matière
olivia grégoire cette taxe elle doit
rapporter 400 millions d'euros cette
année ce sont des entreprises qui font
des milliards de bénéfices
est-ce qu'on n'est pas plus dans la taxe
symbolique qu'efficace non il fallait le
faire tout le monde se se gargarisait en
disant qu'on n'arriverait jamais à le
faire on l'a fait on est en train
d'ailleurs d'embarquer des pays ocde et
des pays européens nous
aujourd'hui plusieurs pays alliés à nos
côtés alors même que nous étions assez
seul il ya quelques mois
2 je salue la détermination de bruno le
maire sur le sujet qui a été total 3 650
millions de d'euros l'année prochaine
dont 400 cette année 650 l'année
prochaine 4 ne rien faire n'est pas une
option
l'europe est la solution et j'espère que
nous pourrons bientôt la retirer puisque
une taxe européenne devrait pouvoir voir
le jour
merci beaucoup les agresseurs étaient
avec nous cette semaine
un merci thibault je vous dis au revoir
thibault puisque vous nous quittez merci
d'avoir été avec nous toute cette saison
on se retrouve après la suspension des
travaux parlementaires avaient kathia
gilder merci à tous a très vite
[Musique]